NIGHT, UKRAINE
REPORTING N ROCKET LDN
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
RT OF RAMPED UP RUSSIAN
ATACKS.
S OF SERIOUS
DESTRUCTION AFTE STRIKES
INFRASTRUCTURE.RGY
UKRAINE.WO MAJOR THINGS BEGINNI
DAE THE FOUR REGNS
ANNEXED UNDER MARTIAL LAW IN TH
BLACKOUTS AS UKRAINIANS NAVIGATE
SERIOUS HITS ON THEIR
INUCTURE CONTINUOUSLY.
WHAT IS THE OVERALL MOOD THERE,
>> RepOF
RESILIENCE, A SENSE AT THINGS
ARE GOG H .
THAT THE WAR HAS ENTERED ANOTHER
ANHEE RUSSIAN
INSTALLED PU
THAT 15,000 PEOPLE WE
EVACUATED YEST
AND I THINK BEST TT THE WORDRT
NOT GETTING A LOT OFHOICE.
SEEN VIDEO CLIPS WITH FAR
FEWER PEOPLE A LVI.
BUT THAT SAME  RUSSIAN
INSTALLED GOVERNOR THERE IWING
WILL COME BACK CONTINUE TO
TAE TERRITORY.
TA ON THE WILL GO AS FAR A
BLACK SEA
OFFICIAL THEY'RE ON THE BACK
FOOT BUT I THINK T THAT.
ARE BEINT  BACK FOOT F UKRAINE
OF ELECTRICITY SUPPLIES.
AS YOU SAY, THERE NOW
CONTROLLED POWER OUTAGP TO
FOUR HOURSSO AREAS.
KHARKIV, TO NAME
TWO REGIONS IN THE NORTH WHERE
THEY ARE NOW HAVING THES
, Y CONTROLS,
SMO AREAS WITHOUT WATER AND
STREET LIGHTING WILL BE CH
ELECTR DS BE RUNNING
AND THE ADVICE THE GOVER
GIVING TO PEOPLES QUIT
SERIOUS AND STNI
STOCK UP WIT AE YOUR PHONES EPRE
D READY.
THEY A PION
FOR THE SSY THAT THE
ELECTRIC SON COULD GET
WOE.STRY OF FOREIGS  THEY'RE WO
TRY TO GET ENERGY GENERATING
SUPPLIES INTO THE COUNTRY.
BUT AS WE KNOW, THESE REPAIR
W EQUIPMENT  TIME.
N Y ATTHE MOMENT BECAUSE THE
IN THE SPACEF JUST ABOUT TEN
DAYS HAVE IMPOSED A QUITE SEVERE
TR
UNMANAGEABLE TWO WEEKS AGO
AL>> ENERGY BLACKMAIL.S COLDER .
NIC ROBERTSON, THANK YOU.
>>> WELL THE.SPARTMENT SAID IT S
EVIDENCE THAT RUSSIA IS USIN
MITAD ITHO 13  DRONE
EGION.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE MAYOR OF
MYKOLA.
IS DT FOR JOINING US.
FEW , EIGHT MONTHS FOR YOU
THHO OUR CITIZENS THERE.
13 KAMIKAZE DRONES OVER TH
REGION.AT AREO BEST
PROTECT YOUR RESIDENTS?
>>ALL, WE ARE HAVE
DISTANCE OF 50 KILOMETERS FROM
KHERSON, SO THEY BS OMTHATION AT
FOR ABT  MYKOLAIV. WE HAVE J
, THE WON
EXPLOSION.
ANWH HEAR THE
EXPOSITION, THERE SHOULDE
AL
ANTI-AIRCRAFT TROOPS.
HITHEM WITH
HIT TH A WE HAVE SOME
9:00.M WE GOT FOUR ROCKETS OC-3.
UNATELY NO ONE HAS DIE
BUT WE HAVE SOME HURT.
>> YOU WERE A CITY OF A LITTLE
UNDER 500,000 FORE THE W
YOUR CITIZENACCESSO D WATEERE F
HAV
F HALF MILLION.
WE NEED TO SUPPLY
WH WATER,LEND
HEATING AND PUBLIC TRANSPO
SO WE  I MN WE
HAVE WATER SUPPLY CAUS
RUSSIANS BOMBARDED PIPESM
TH RIVERKHERSOGIOW WE'RE
TAKING FR RIVERS
BUT THIS WATER IS
CAN'IT BUT WE COULD USE
IT FORNG AND FORLETS
AND EVERYTHING.
SO WPL
BOTTLES, REFILL THO HOMEPE ME TC
FOR DRNG
FOR SURE, RUSS NOWTT
OUINUCTUREELTR
INFRASTRUCTURE, TRY STATIONS ANR
S.USES.
LET'S CALL IGE, , OUR COMPANIESN
IC CRIMINAL AN SERVICMPIERE REA
ELECTRICITY AND GAANHEG
FA
>> YOU MENTIONED YOUOXHE
NOW THAT WE ARE SEEING T
THOUSANDS OF RESTS
REEVACUATED AND FORCIBLE
MY TO RUSSIA I'M CURIOUSNY OF T
YOU, IF YOU ARE TAKING ANYF
THOSE RESIDENTS OF
YO CIT
>> WE M WITH THE
SERVICE IN THE BEGINNING OF
R,S BLOCKEE Y FROM KHERSON T.
THE CITIZENSF KHERSON HAVE MYKO.
SO THEY HAVE TO R IN
RUSSIA.
I DON'LIE
T 50,000
IMAGES.
BUT THEY USELL
IPCUATE PEOPLE FROM
THINK IT IS AT MOST.
THE MAIN THIY O
THIS, WHY THEY EVACUATE
VI CIVILIANS AINERM
WON'T HARM.
WE WON'T KILL UKRAINIANS
THEY'RE OUR TEAM
I IN IDEA THAT WE  UNDER OCCUPAN
WANT T
THEMSELVES AND SAYING TH
W ATTACKING
THEI.IS IS THE MAIN THING WE
NEED TO THINK AND RE
JOURNALISTS HAVE TO SHOW THIS
PIKE.
>> CONSTANTLY USING PROPAGANDA .
AND OBVIOUSLY  IA SIGN O
THEIR WEAKNESS AND BE ON THE